hey guys Ryan right here today's a
special day because I've already seen
this trailer so I'm gonna let some to
hot ass [ __ ] fill in for me hey guys
welcome to the real rejects on ass
[ __ ] part one I'm Samantha a Chevelle
I'm Taylor Bradley thanks for watching
we get to watch this spongebob feel like
we kind of left us in charge oh my god
what can we do oh do we have anything
that we could show that's embarrassing
mini eclairs its these is coffee table
and and the tattoos we found tape with
them fur on it I don't really know what
this is but there's like spikes hi my
name is Ryan
I own the Toyota Camry someone hit my
car and ran but we are about there's
information top-secret information and
full of information he has Mickey ears
we can do this
okay guys do you believe in us later I
believe in this no I believe in us now
iCloud later okay are you ready let's do
this
are you ready yeah we have this program
in a recent sonar scan of the ocean
floor scientists recorded a seven
before earth like white noise for
paramount animation and nickelodeon
movies big boy without it to be a
complete breakdown of social order
aren't you overreacting a bit go to the
apocalypse no get a glitter service all
right all secondary characters come with
me two hours with place maybe this guy
knows it's work this
why are they should I wear off 2015 what
are you doing
far better you mean
made for people it happens when I'm
nervous
dad the only way to stop a supervillain
is to become superheroes
suits me Patrick
take two I'm seeing a bright life this
is better much thank you a sponge on the
floor in 3d justices first soft suit
maybe we should have picked a better
superpower for you get dressed
oh my goodness
I don't know what to think I'm so
excited I know a couple things to think
one I'm bummed that doesn't have the
original music - I really love spongebob
but I'm also a little disappointed that
it's not all cartoon like drawn cuz I
have soft spot my heart for that I do
like it being underwater all the time
you - but they did a good job with the
3d rendition I think like it was the
best that they could have done with that
I just I like it just drawn I like it
classic I grew up with the show I'm
still gonna watch it I think it's gonna
be funny but I have to bring up mr.
Krabs and his lover oh oh my gosh this
is for children and their I feel like
why is he - and I was gonna all the
parents are to be like I am that's just
weird Halloween kids yep and I never
wear for Halloween Bob I'm gonna be mr.
Krabs in the leather suit no you don't
the batteries died huh we got to wrap it
up we gotta wrap oh no we didn't get to
do shoutouts can we just do our own ever
you want to share old Greg shout-out to
old Greg actor of old Greg if you're
watching this we love you because oh
have heart half heart just old grade
there and who else do we want to shut up
I would like to shut out 48 hours
theater company oh yeah that's a good
one I forgot about our theater Gordon
ours production yes that's good we have
a Facebook page Facebook on flash 48
hours theater th EA T ar e please don't
like it cuz we're awesome yeah we run it
and wouldn't you want us running a
company cuz if he seems so professional
right we are actually very professional
and I have a youtube channel go like it
I'll be posting some of our adventuring
in the business I go on a lot of
adventures it's kind of difficult to
believe how many adventures we go on
yeah did you see SpongeBob and Patrick
when they had all the cotton can they
would like oh that's us everyday the
week except we're in a car we're like oh
okay thanks subscribe and subscribe to
the real rejects because it's awesome
the bomb diggity
unless you're offended easily in which
case I I probably wouldn't subscribe no
I would still subscribe I would still
watch him but I would in subscribe
subscribe subscribe you need to loosen
up anyway if you're uptight